right baby from Barcelona
[Applause]
it is
shut up hey guys it's Peter Brown
standing in for freelance reviewer
Nathan Didem for his review of FIFA 17
being consistently good can bring its
own problems among the highlight
gameplay changes in this year's FIFA we
have better throw ins low-driven shots
and the ability to control the ball from
a long keeper kick welcomed improvements
sure but still pity the marketing guide
has to make these sound exciting maybe
that's why FIFA 17 a football game that
checks all the usual boxes you'd expect
also throws in a more glamorous and
unexpected addition the journey
[Music]
the journey is a new story based mode
centering on Alex hunter a young player
breaking into professional football what
was sad stay on your feet Alex terrible
it's built from a mix of gameplay
dialogue and cutscenes which depict
Alex's evolving relationships with his
family and teammates and ultimately
whether his talent is enough to
kick-start a dream career his jaw I'm
addict choice within the journey is in
practice pretty limited outside of the
initial opportunity to choose which
Premier League side Hunter joins once
you start leveling up you can directly
apply upgrade points to specific skills
but fixed plot points underpin the story
and they happen no matter how you're
performing on the pitch or behaving off
of it
the journey sounds the occasional
awkward dramatic note interactions
between characters can seem forced and
sometimes the locations themselves are
quiet and empty giving the scene an
unreal disconnected feel and yet for all
that the journey captures something at
existing parts of FIFA never have
despite its rough edges there are
moments here that deliver a kind of
brute emotional force sure it lacks
sophistication but the journey has
something and it succeeds in attaching
an added emotional weight to your
actions on the field but if that phone
doesn't ring
don't give up as for the rest of this
year's update FIFA 17 feels like a round
of unglamorous but welcome housekeeping
after the relatively thorough gameplay
changes of last year EA has touted the
switch to the frostbite engine and
presently wide shots of stadiums look
very pretty especially at night and with
mist hanging in the air but elsewhere
you'd be hard-pressed to spot the
differences and some locations in the
journey look a little flat in
characterless the gameplay improvements
this year are typify by much-needed
tweaks but also feel like the kind of
changes you only get around to when
there's nothing really pressing to
address
so now throw-ins can be dummied much
like a fake shot giving players a way to
move defenders around and get a better
chance of keeping possession free kicks
and penalties have been freed up so you
can choose your angle of approach and
charge your cross or shot much more like
you would in a regular game physical
play too has been refined so that
holding the left trigger down is now the
way to let the game know in attack or
defense that you want your players to
engage physically with the other team it
is a small tweak but it's one that
removes some of the mysteries
surrounding jostling while defending and
seems very useful for holding on to the
ball wall in possession finally the
inclusion of low-driven shots as an
appreciable new wrinkle to offensive
play nail the timing and you're able to
power efforts on goal low and accurately
finally ending the years-long reality
defying rule that more power must equal
more hype there's also the fact that
reality or a small slice of it at least
has been invited into career mode your
objectives and managing a club are now
more specifically tailored to the club
in question it's a relatively simple way
of removing the modes previous
one-size-fits-all feel while giving a
sense of individuality to every
playthrough with a new Club ultimate
team remains FIFA's biggest draw with EA
choosing to add rather than tinker with
a winning formula the most notable
addition our squad building challenges
which require you to construct sides
with certain conditions using only
players of two different nationalities
or with a minimum chemistry level and
then submit them for rewards it's a very
smart piece of design not only giving
you a use for the scores of bronze and
silver players you accrue over the
course of a season but also making play
of the subtle and sophisticated problem
solving that already underpins Ultimate
Team systems this year's FIFA then can
be fairly summarised as one big change
that doesn't quite pay off and a lot of
small ones that do the journey is
engaging enough but right now it's not
the reason to buy FIFA 17 that remains a
combination of still excellent
fundamental gameplay and ultimate team
put together with an improved career
mode and best-in-class presentation and
FIFA 17 is this year's strongest
football game
for the maybe something on here
the defender had to cut that out and he
did vital interception
[Applause]